soit j'appelle ton père soit je te mets
une paire de gifles ouais ok pour la
paire de gifles et des coups ne me fais
pas dit les choses est-ce que vous avez
déjà volé un truc vachement même quand
vous étiez petit ou un truc pas mal et
vous avez déjà volé l'orangé volé
l'orangé du marchand
non j'ai déjà volé mais en fait c'était
pas fait exprès voilà c'est quoi je me
suis rendu compte quand je suis sorti
que j'avais en fait j'avais la poussette
de mon fils comme ça j'avais mis une
bouteille de champagne
voilà pour finir mes courses comme par
hasard sur foot il y avait les manteaux
pardessus et cetera au moment de passer
la caisse géo j'avais oublié non et vous
avez entre saint clément je me suis dit
oui c'est bien acquis mais françois de
la chaire chic
je vais vous la livre et qui a déjà volé
un truc qui vous avez des gens n'étaient
sûrs mais sans faire exprès à l'arrivée
de bain dans une cabine d'essayage
je suis parti avec le haut sans faire
exprès donc je suis arrivée chez moi
juste avec le haut et je me suis bas
c'est vraiment trop con donc j'ai été
lendemain juste pour mac juste pour vos
lui le bas j'ai pris le bas voilà vous
avez plus bas où il avait volé le ba ba
de les voler voilà je connais bien la
performance à ce format séparément a
battu rendez vous elle paye et milow oui
bah oui vous savez tous plus je le dis
pas d'achat là
alors déjà volé quelque chose si mal
alors isabelle oms j'ai envie de savoir
ce que vous avez volé vous ai fait oui
des cerises
non je volais des cerises dans les
armées qui revendait devant le collège
saint-vaast front à l'est pendant ce pas
vrai un franc le kilo
vous étiez le vendeur de seriner ah
ouais j'ai été piqué vous êtes fait
dénoyautées oui isabelle non elle c'est
un pari entre copines de piquer des
trucs à tant de luttes étudiantes de
toujours en grève on avait le temps et
donc on avait petit à petit en premier
dit sont de plus en plus de valeur et un
jour c'était un manteau et moi je me
suis dit je suis doué je prends le
manteau et toupie à la à l'entrée voilà
et donc comme un objectif savait rien
pleurer et ben
et un poussin fait honnête oui mais
c'est laurent voulait le rendre rendra
savant de potes sens du rythme copine
avec le jeune oui bien sûr mais moi
aussi ma mère a volé des trucs qu'on
cherche et trouve que toi t'es pas
gênant isabelle et la chance qu'elle
vise à baisser à l'époque qui avait pas
d'alarmé pas de vidéo surveillance avait
rien sa dernière et n'a toujours pas
d'humour
ma mère si normes et israël on va lever
le pied sur les anecdotes a vraiment eu
médias rivière médias sur israël pas
vraiment non mais ça va pas mal aidé et
soutien gorge un mois je prépare un
mollet c'est un derrière certains c'est
pas grave on va prendre un bon cachet
à tout le monde est fatigué tout le
monde est fatigué oui moi j'avais acheté
un sac chez saks à new york ça très très
beau sac et quand je suis arrivée chez
moi je me suis aperçu qu'ils avaient pas
la bandoulière et donc j'étais super g
n'est parce qu'en fait 1 500 bondit
guerre ce n'est pas pratique dans pour
sa tournée à la boutique ils ont pas
voulu donner la bandoulière
maintenant ils ont estimé que c'était ma
faute je l'avais voulu et ardu et
évidemment je les volets elle a volé une
bourde oublier cette fois que je traduis
j'ai un peu peur non maintenant vous
êtes vraiment grave franchement pas
vraiment castaldi n'a rien volé face à
lui il ya croyez avoir volé il est un
truc hyper gros face il était petit
atelier très énervant c'est les pièces
détachées faisait pour la machine à café
quand on perd ou on casse une pièce non
plus jamais vous la vendre alors plutôt
que la vendre
jeudi se répand dans le magasin et hop
je démonte un petit bout c'était bien du
tt connu la dompter machine à café c'est
pas très vieux ouais non non lus à vous
lire récemment
merci oui moi je suis très très fière
dont je vole pas il a su infos que j'ai
je me suis fait piquer ses des potes qui
met est mis dans ma poche
ça chante à mesa les sonnets j'allais me
fait rigoler mais moi j'ai trop peur
pour sa déjà pas de café un vol
incroyable jeu il ya prescription
maintenant je peux le dire c'était le
salon de la moto à paris est le dernier
jour quand on remballe tout toutes les
motos etc
il s'habille avec une tenue de garagiste
tenue bleue comme ça il a foncé vers un
stand d'à grand fabricant de motos comme
ça il arrivé il ya eu plein de gens d
intérim et acsta il arrivé là depuis la
moto la retire les béquilles il est pas
à tirer comme ça personne lui a rien dit
avec une moto de 9 passes et leur sang
etc est énorme le bec et 2004 avec un
exemple d'honnêteté ce que vous avez
déjà volé quelque chose votre réponse
est dans la phrase merci d'autres
devraient maintenant tu 2e 6 ha non non
j'ai pris une paire de gifles en
remercie cosmo vous avez volé quoi impôt
très nette moi alors que j'étais j'étais
un grand magasin dans le 6ème parisien
un beau marché voilà globe c'est très
bien j'avais plein quarantaine
collectionner les gommes
c'est les grosses fautes des fautes et
celle des métiers ou ségo à une étagère
chez moi j'étais très fier
quarante trois dom et j'avais volé deux
hommes que je n'avais pas le vigile m'a
vu alors en plus papa est avocat donc le
vigile m'a vu il m'a chopé et il m'a dit
soit tu rends les deux soit tu voyais et
soit tu sois tu revenais de blessure
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle ton père soit je te mets une
paire de gifles
ouais ok j'ai dit bah ok pour la paire
de gifles et des coups ne me fais pas
partie d'après de père est plus sûr
participants de l'est de gaulle et de
grands matches comme celui-là ça se
passera pas comme ça aujourd'hui ça
c'est l'ancien maths qui se déroule au
niveau vrai jespere quil marveaux les
deux hommes ont cependant pas
[Musique]